In Italy we have a famous song:
In case the World is falling down, I go back
a little bit to not get hurt. But what if an
nuclear bomb were to fall on the City where
I live in Tuscany (which is Prato)? This is
something I ask myself with a bit of paranoia.
How much "further back" am I supposed to ensure
I don't vaporize instantly? After all, the
dogma of this era seems to be "never say never":
pandemics, wars, Italy out of the World
Cup. Meanwhile, everyone wants to build
their own bunker. Yes, there are companies that
specialize in this. Now you know. In Switzerland,
just to say, since 1963 it is mandatory by law
to provide every building with a bomb shelter,
while in Italy we don't have any regulatory
plan providing for the construction of bunkers.
At least in theory. But, hey, what’s the deal.
We can always use our cellars as bunkers.
After getting all the permissions, of course.
However, since a bunker costs several tens of
thousands of dollars and since I am not paid
enough, if an atomic bomb were to fall on my
little town, Prato, I would have no choice
but to run away. Hopefully with a fast car.
Luckily for me, a simulator, Nukemap, created
by historian Alex Wellerstein, has been around
for several years now, showing the range of
action, and destruction, of an atomic device.
We'll take a look at it, but before I give you
any unjustified anxiety, I wanted to ask myself:
what are the nations that possess the warheads
capable to unleash the atomic holocaust?
These are not so many, and the so funny "club of
the atom" is currently limited to nine members: on
the one hand you have the " classic" United
States, Russia, France, the United Kingdom,
China, all of the signatories of the Treaty
on the Non-Proliferation of Nuclear Weapons,
but on the other hand you have 4 countries
that are not yet members of such agreement,
namely India, Pakistan, North Korea and Israel,
even if the latter is only unofficially part of
it. Apart from a couple of them, they all
seem to be nice and quiet. But surprise:
we Italians too have nuclear warheads at our
disposal. Oh well, they are not really ours.
According to the NATO nuclear sharing plan, it has
been decided to involve in the "nuclear warfare"
also some "non-nuclear" countries
of the alliance like us italians.
Shared strategies and planning, mostly, but also
supply of warheads. So much non proliferation...
I can smell it. The United States (and who
otherwise?) have lent Italy, Belgium, Germany,
the Netherlands and Turkey their own toys that,
of course, we all cannot use at our pleasure.
You all understand? Don't play with those gifts.
The bombs are guarded by U.S. soldiers and without
U.S. codes they can't be used. But in case of
war, we still have to prove that we are capable
of using them, and we cannot afford to fall
off the wagon. According to a report by analyst
Hans Kristensen, of the Natural Resources Defense
Council, in 2005 in Italy there were 90 warheads:
50 in the base of Aviano and 40 in the base
of Ghedi Torre. Today the estimates point a
total of forty warheads, but it seems also to
be a real secret bilateral agreement between
our country and the United States, called Stone
Ax, which would provide for a further deployment
of American nuclear weapons on our territory.
Making an estimate of the warheads currently in
circulation is a bit complicated but one thing
is certain: Russia and the USA share about 90%
of the world's nuclear weapons. According
to the Federation of American Scientist,
in the first part of 2022 the estimated number
of warheads around the world is 12.700. Of these,
except those being dismantled, the actual
warheads for military use are 9400,
but only 3700 are the ones currently deployed
and operational, 2000 even in "state of alert",
ready for immediate use. Russia would be in
the first place with 5977 warheads, followed by
the United States with 5 thousand 428, but if we
take into account only the deployed warheads, the
United States would have a slight advantage: 1744
against 1588. Just to understand the difference in
level with the rest of the world, in third place
China boasts "only" three hundred fifty warheads,
up to 20 of North Korea. You have to eat more
uranium, Dear Kim. But we should go easy on good
old Kim, apparently he has some very dangerous new
toys now. In fact, Pyongyang's latest tests have
glorified the power of the new Hwasong 17 missiles
capable of reaching American and European soil.
Of course, so far they have not gone further
than Japan. A coincidence, one might say.
Okay, potentially Kim could hit us right now. What
about the others? France would have no problem to
hit their beloved cousins from Italy and since
in the past they have already given us their
warheads (Zidane World Cup head scene) I would
be careful. Also USA and UK may have no problem
to send us their missiles and neither Russia.
Pakistan and India perhaps would not make it: both
the Pakistani Shaheen and the Indian Agni have a
more limited range. After all they only care about
destroying each other and maybe hitting China.
China, with its DF-41 missiles and especially
with the new hypersonic models, (when they'll be
ready for use), has all the requirements to be a
good candidate to destroy my town in Tuscany.
Come on, bring it on. You and what army? Mh,
they sound convincing. So, what would happen if a
nuclear warhead fell right here in the exact spot
where I live? Let's say for example, a Russian
warhead hits the ground right here. Purely random
example. First of all, according to the experts
of the Bulletin of the Atomic Scientists, it is
to be believed that the nuclear warheads today at
the disposal of the Russians are around a charge
of 800 kilotons which, to be clear, would be
equivalent to 800 thousand tons of dynamite. Those
of hiroshima and Nagasaki were between 15 and 20
kilotons. Intercepting a nuclear Intercontinental
ballistic missile is technically possible, but
very difficult and unpredictable, given the
parabolic trajectory of the ICBM. The most basic
system is basically just shooting a missile at
the missile. During the Cold War, that’s what
Russians and Americans called “Anti-ballistic
missile”. But we never had the honor to experiment
the effectiveness of this tactic so far. Hiroshima
and Nagasaki were the only two history cases
of nukes dropped on civilians, and Japan didn’t
have any anti-ballistic missile at that time. The
idea would be to hit the ICBM and make it blow up
somewhere other than its intended target. This
with all the consequences it may have on the
atmosphere. Anti-ballistic systems are present
in various countries and are still under full
development. Nowadays, India’s ABM system is
capable of intercepting missiles up to two
thousand six hundred km and potentially to
five thousand km. In a war scenario, no one has
activated their own defense system. Yet. And so,
we can only speculate. In a report by the American
Physical Society Panel on Public Affairs,
even the Americans seems to have a limited
capability to intercept an intercontinental
balistic missile. In this study it is stated:
“the current capabilities are low and will likely
continue to be low for the next 15 years”. So,
strikes from North Korea against the US are not
fully prevented yet. And we are speaking about 20
warheads. Imagine six thousands Russian nukes.
Goodbye Sirs. Proposed by the Administration,
The U.S. Ground-Based Midcourse Defense, also
known as GMD, is operational in both Alaska
and California and provides more protection
against the Nuclear threat from North Korean
missiles or launches from Russia or China,
but is likely less effective against missiles
launched from the Middle East. Here in Italy
are developing the Aster 30 Block II system,
with a range of three thousand km. In the meantime
we need to survive without it and look for two
NATO defense sites, one in Romania, the other
one in Poland. This means only one thing: boom.
Detonated a few hundred meters above Piazza
del Duomo – I Hope Our Dear Bishop forgives
me- the explosion would generate a ball of
fire and hot air, of millions of degrees
Fahrenheit, that would instantly vaporize
everything within a radius of 880 meters,
for an area of about 2 square kilometers. The
shockwave will then spread fatally within an
area of 14 square kilometers from the explosion
site, severely damaging and razing most buildings
to the ground. In general, anyone who manages
to survive within a radius of 2 kilometers and
380 - which includes me - will have a short time
because the radiation will prove fatal within
a month. at 4 km and 760 meters The buildings
from the explosion will report moderate damage,
but the risk of fire will be high though. At a
distance of 11 km and 400 meters, for a total
area of 409 kilometers so well beyond Prato up to
municipalities such as Sesto Fiorentino, Signa,
Campi Bisenzio, Poggio a Caiano and Carmignano
(but not the much hated city of Pistoia ...), the
hot air will cause third degree burns but you will
not even feel them, it is very likely that your
pain receptor nerves will be already fatally
damaged. Finally, the explosion will affect
a total area of 4 hundred seventy seven square
km around the Cathedral of Prato and depending
on where the wind will blow, there will be a
radioactive rain of one hundred eighty one km,
which will affect at different intensity a
total area of four thousand square km. The
mushroom cloud on the ashes of Prato will be 19
km high, with a radius of the head of 25 km. So,
if I wanted to save myself at least from the
damage of the explosion, I would have to move
at least 12 km from the center of Prato. I could
be safe in Florence and yes, even in Pistoia. We
from Prato have some long lasting disputes with
those in Pistoia. In case you're luckier than me,
you could always live near a large "public"
fallout shelter. The luckiest ones in Italy live
in the province of Verona, in Affi, where there
is the largest bunker of its kind in our country,
located in the bowels of Mount Moscal. Built
in the Sixties to house a NATO command post,
it is 13 thousand square meters wide and
can accommodate almost 1000 people. Once
well-stocked, for some years now it has
been dismantled and is now almost unusable.
You can also try it in Trentino, under Mount Mais
in Val di Non, where you will find the Gampen
Bunker. Being bombed during World War II, our
country has hundreds if not thousands of shelters,
from private to public shelters. In nearby
Florence you could look for one of the many
city shelters built to escape from the bombings:
from the undergrounds of the Basilica of San
Lorenzo to Palazzo Vecchio. If you find yourself
in Florence during a nuclear attack, observe on
the walls the presence of an R, indicating the
proximity to a bunker. In Torino, then, under
Piazza del Risorgimento, there is still an active
shelter capable of accommodating one thousand one
hundred fifty people, though during the war
it happened to welcome twice as many people.
Just as in Naples, the population found refuge
from bombing in the network of nineteenth-century
tunnels built by the Bourbons. Famous in Milan
are shelter 87, under an elementary school,
and the network of Breda
bunkers in the Parco Nord.
In Rome, Mussolini and Savoia had their
own bunkers with blackjack and hookers.
Today you won't exactly find this luxury
in the bunker under the park of Villa Ada,
once a Royal Residence wanted by King Vittorio
Emanuele the Third. You will find instead an
anonymous and disturbing parking lot. Mussolini
had two bunkers, one under Palazzo venezia
and another at Villa torlonia, both in
Rome, but they were not even completed. But
45 km from Rome, in the meanders of Mount Soratte
in the proximity of the town of Sant'Oreste,
you can find a vast tangle of underground
tunnels, long 4 km and designed to accommodate
the highest charges of the army. These tunnels
were then partially converted into a bomb shelter
by NATO during the Cold War. Yet, if some
ill-intentioned nation wants to attack us,
we should expect more than anything else a
direct bombing towards military installations,
such as Aviano and Ghedi, with consequences
that Nukemap itself refuses to consider.
I apologize if I too have provided you with
a daily dose of atomic anxiety. Just in case,
remember your potassium Iodide pills for radiation
and Nukemap in your hand to calculate the damage
and the probability of survival. An advice: DO
NOT simulate the explosion of the Tsar bomb,
the most powerful ever built and designed
by Russia. You may experience nightmares.